hello next week it's
strasbourg several big files
await the deputies for the
penultimate session before the summer break
here is an overview of
how to better protect
asylum seekers in europe today the
procedures are still too different
from one  country to country the asylum package
proposes a set of common rules
for all of the proposals the
states will have a maximum of six months to
decide on each request if the
asylum seeker is a minor
the state will have to provide him with a
representative it is also a question
of extending the use of rhodes ac the
register of fingerprints to
the national authorities to better identify
the identity of asylum seekers and
incidentally to fight more effectively
against
terrorism aid to the most deprived comes down to
the agenda before the expiry of
the european food aid program at the
end of 2013 the debates continue on the
amount to be allocated to the new
j program  o destitute 2.5 billion euros
proposed by the european commission it
is not enough considers the rapporteur of the
file in parliament and mehr costello
but it is better than nothing there is urgency
for the millions of europeans concerned
by the  extreme poverty is a
question of survival how to
overcome organized crime in europe
once again the disparities in rules
between states generate loopholes which
favor
money laundering in particular among the measures proposed by
the rapporteur salvatore iacono he  we need to
agree on a common definition
of what a mafia-type crime is, the
deputy also proposes the eventual creation
of a real park and Europeans
working in close collaboration
with europol and, as usual, distinguished
guests are expected  in
strasbourg slovenian president borut
pahor and his portuguese counterpart anibal
cavaco silva will address
MEPs as their two countries
face an unprecedented crisis  nt
slovenia tries to escape an
international aid plan by selling off
some of its large
public companies while portugal
reinforces austerity measures to
get out of the budgetary abyss
that's all for this time have a good week